wer waren überzeugendsten wer hat dieses
Duell gewonnen ich lese das hier einmal
vor denn sie sind frisch rein klarer
Sieger nach der Umfrage bei den Kollegen
der ard-infried-test ist Olaf Scholz 41%
auf Platz 2 man kann sagen abgeschlossen
abgeschlagen Armin Laschet mit 27% und
die Statistin naturgemäß auf Platz drei
Annalena baerbock mit 25% ganz hinten
Thomas nach den Statements die sie hier
gerade gesehen haben passt das so
ungefähr ja also so bewirbt man sich um
den Betriebsrat bei Rewe sage ich mal
das ist das das war dermaßen teilweise
ebenso in dieser rheinischen
wählen Sie mich zum Vertreter der dir zu
sagen
Sprecher ich werde dafür sorgen dass der
Heilige Geist über alle gleichmäßig
ausgeschüttet wird das hatte sowas
benefiziertenhaftes und bei Scholz das
war so trocken und trüge aber wie wir
sind wir sind vielleicht nicht so
vielleicht passen die zu uns sind wir
oder fangen wir mit Nena an sind wir
trocken und drücke ist das was wir
verdient haben ich habe das also dieses
Fazit von Herr Laschet fand ich ehrlich
gesagt gerade gut nehmen wir mal die
rheinländische Art die habe ich auch
dementsprechend verzeiht sie ihm kann
ich auch nicht anders wäre sonst relativ
unangenehm hier dagegen zu reden aber
der hat ein ganz wichtigen Satz gesagt
ich werde sie nicht gängeln und das ist
ein Signal worauf ich eigentlich schon
den ganzen Tag ist das nicht eigentlich
klar muss man sagen
es ist nicht klar wenn man sich die
letzten anderthalb Jahre anschaut wurden
wir dermaßen gegänge die
Meinungsfreiheit wir haben den
schlechtesten Wert seit 1953 in der
Meinung
also dieses ich werde
eigentlich oder also ich muss jetzt auch
mal sagen ich glaube das Armin Laschet
jetzt
wir waren heute viel beim Boxen er hat
jetzt k.o Schlag gekriegt ich glaube
wenn du wenn du so unter Druck stehst
wenn du wenn es so auf dich einprasselt
wenn du in den Medien auch denen die die
dir eher Wohlwollen gegenüberstehen
normalerweise hörst dass du es nicht
kannst wenn du
Umfrageergebnisse hast die immer noch
unten gehen wenn du dann in dieses Duell
lassen wir mal Frau Bernburg Weg rein
gehst wenn du nicht schlecht warst das
war wirklich wir sehen ihn gerade live
wenn du nicht schlecht warst dann gehört
viel dazu jetzt noch so auszusehen weil
ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass der
auch innerlich mal zusammen sagt alles
andere wäre ja unmenschlich und ob das
jetzt dann noch reicht auf letztes Mal
mit ihm zufrieden das ist doch schon
einiges ja
aber dieser Satz ist schwer die sie
nicht gerne ich würde sagen Mensch ins
Kinder wenn ich Bundeskanzler wäre dann
können sie
all seinen Gesten sie das machen was sie
endlich wollen was sie können
auch gleich machen
[Musik]